First of is Intermodel Consistency. The analysis process may have
produce multiple diagrams, each of which we can think of as a model.
These must be checked for inter-model consistency. For
example, if you produce use cases, in, in the form of a use case diagram,
you want to make sure that you have some representation for
the individual use cases. Possibly in terms of a communication. Or
sequence diagram, and the names would have to match up.
Similarly, if you have classes that have complex behavior, you want to
make sure that you have a StateChart for those classes, and in the StateChart,
any events, actions and activities correspond to methods in the class model.
And, if you, have data conditions on your StateChart.
Those data conditions are going to refer to attributes. It had better be,
the case that those attributes are listed in your class model diagram.